promises a promise is a proxy or
placeholder for a value that you may not
know when the promise is created you
don't know exactly when an asynchronous
method is going to finish in your
program promises allow you to do
something as soon as an asynchronous
method or action does finish instead of
immediately returning the final value
the asynchronous method returns a
promise to supply the value at some
point in the future a pending promise
can either be fulfilled with a value or
rejected with a reason or it at this
point the Associated handlers will be
called one way to create a promises was
with the new promise there are other
ways to create a promise such as the
fetch API but here is here's the basic
usage you put new promise and then
you're gonna pass in a function with
resolved and reject at this point in the
promise you're gonna do an asynchronous
task so we don't know for sure when it's
gonna end and then it's up to the
developer to manually call resolve or
reject from within the body of the
callback based on the result of the
given task
if the asynchronous task was successful
you're gonna call resolve and they're
gonna pass in whatever you want listed
as success else you're gonna call reject
and you're gonna pass in whatever you
want such as failure so this that's how
you set up the promise and then down
here is where we call the promise and
the then function is whatever you're
gonna do after the asynchronous task and
the promise completes so as soon as this
complete this task up here it's going to
call the bin function and it's gonna do
something with the result and so this
function will not be called until
whatever the asynchronous task is
resolves if there's an error it will go
down to the dot catch function and it's
going to do something with the error
this was just the basic usage of a
promise now I'll show you another
example that does a little more so let's
scroll down here so this was created to
show exactly what's happening when you
use a promise so in this example we're
going to create a few different promises
I want to keep track of how many
promises we have
this is the function test promise and
you can see we're gonna call this three
times at the end so we can create three
different promises to see how they
resolve and each promise we create by
running the function is going to have a
different number associated with it here
this promise count equals plus plus
promise counts so first we're going to
cancel that log this promise count so if
it's the first one that's gonna say one
started sink code started so we're gonna
see all this in the console over here
and then we're going to create the new
promise inside the prompts we're gonna
console that log that the promise is
started and the async code is started
and then right here says this is only an
example create a synchronism so in this
example function we are going to create
it to be asynchronous by setting a
timeout for a random number of seconds
to simulate that it's asynchronous and
we don't know when it's going to be
resolved so then we're going to resolve
this promise count so that means we're
going to send out what number promise
this is so let's go down here P 1 that
means the promise that we create up here
that then so once this P 1 promise it
resolves it's going to run this then
function and it's going to have a value
that value comes from up here when we
resolved and we sent this promise count
into the then function here and now
we're going to cancel that log the value
that's what number promise we're on
remember there's three promise that
we're going to create down below and
it's gonna say promise fulfilled async
code terminated and if there's an error
it's going to cancel that log handle
rejected promise and it's going to tell
the reason
and after this promise is wrong it in
our code it's going to console that log
the promise count and that the promise
made and seam code is terminated
nated so let's run then and see exactly
what happens now let me you can move the
console log out a little bit so you can
see console one started sync code
started one promise start async code
started one promise made cinco
terminated now one thing interesting
about this is that the promise made sink
code terminate is toward the end of our
code and it hasn't done the promise
fulfilled async code Sherman terminated
yet but that doesn't happen till down at
the very end of our console it says one
promise fulfilled async code terminated
it's going to run this line of the code
promise made distinct code terminated
before it runs this code promise
fulfilled async code terminated because
of this promise with the random number
it's going to take a random amount of
time before it can fulfill the promise
but if you look back over at the console
you see we have one one one and the next
one isn't till the very end so then
we're gonna do the second promise two
two two three three three and all these
are in order started promise started
promise made started promise started
promise made started promise started
promise made but then they fulfill at
different times so first the second one
is going to be fulfilled then the third
one smiley feel fulfilled and then the
first one is going to be fulfilled this
is because of the asynchronous nature of
this function well I hope this helped
you to understand promises a little more
check the links in the description to
learn more about promises and to see
where I got some of the code snippets in
this video don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good